you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
make or break the low-lying developing
nations and islands seeking urgent help
at cop26 to help with the effects of
climate change
we're live on grenada in the caribbean
where islanders are already having to
alter their lives massively because of
global warming
it comes as england's environment agency
issues an adapt or die warning stressing
the country needs to become more
resilient to violent weather bringing
floods and droughts
and a promise from putin russia will
strive to be carbon neutral by 2060 in a
move that matches china
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions now here on the daily climate
show we often look at the challenges
we'll all face in the years to come
because of climate change but for many
countries especially low-lying
developing nations and islands those
challenges are already too real they're
in urgent need of cash to help them
adapt to the changes already locked in
as a result of global warming
most are reliant on the money being
promised by rich nations to help fund
those adaptations
currently less than 25 of the 100
billion dollars a year those developed
nations are being asked for is earmarked
for climate adaptation but for some
that's just not enough and they argue
november's cop 26 summit will be make or
break for them well our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter is
live for us in saint george's the
capital of the caribbean island of
grenada hannah
grenada might be a tiny island but at
the moment it is a powerful symbol of an
almighty row that's brewing about the
amount of money that's available to
those nations that have done the least
to cause the climate crisis but are
suffering the most from it and when you
drive around this island when you meet
people who live here it's easy to see
why it's become such a big issue
grenada is a paradise in peril
the ocean and the tropical weather that
sustain it weaponized by climate change
touching every aspect of life here
telescope bay is on the east of the
island
a community being forced out by the
encroaching sea
makeshift defenses not enough to hold it
back
there is no more choice i have to find
somewhere else
to put this house
patricia richards has been here for
three decades but it's time to leave i
feel angry
because i know it is humans that cause
climate change
we human we did all the wrong things
because right now the sea is up on us
and it keeps on coming
and there is no stuff in it
and it's not just at sea level
more intense rains are destabilizing the
soil
sending homes and businesses tumbling
down the hillsides
all of this will need to be rebuilt
elsewhere they move a road away from a
river that constantly floods
part of a huge effort to protect people
from the effects of climate change that
are already here
on this island alone that's going to
cost hundreds of millions of dollars
that's way more than it can afford and
it's a story that's playing out on
climate vulnerable nations across the
world
that's where simon steele comes in
he is grenada's climate minister and an
increasingly powerful voice amongst a
coalition of dozens of island nations
demanding a massive influx of cash to
help them adapt
survival is such a base term
i want more for my children than
just to survive i want more for my
people i want more for myself than just
to survive
we need to be able to to thrive
the cop 26 climate summit in glasgow is
now just days away for many a last
chance to secure what is needed
i think it's make or break
entire nations will be under water
what price
what price do you put
in the lives of people
what price do you put
on
our culture
our right to exist
it is a warning and a plea to the world
one that the people of this island hope
is heeded as they cope with change they
did not cause do you worry about the
future
yeah
the amount of fish we used to catch
you don't see this among the fish
anymore
it's difficult for us as farmers now to
cook we cannot really plan because we
don't know when it's a rainy season when
it's dry season simply because climate
has changed during this past year we've
lost two crops
back to back that can affect you
financially it can affect you
emotionally mentally physically as world
leaders prepare to make decisions that
will shape the future of our planet
grenada is a symbol
of a looming david and goliath style
battle for funding
one that vulnerable nations are
increasingly determined to win
so the big question is how far are these
island nations this coalition of island
nations willing to go at cop26 to get
what they want will they use their power
because they've been described to me as
a crucial middle voting block uh to you
know get what they want by walking away
or withholding agreement i think the
tone very much
from the people who are representing
these nations is that they want to be
constructive in tone they have hope and
optimism but increasingly in my view
they are desperate they are getting
angry and they are willing
to use their power to be obstructive at
the most important climate summit since
paris hannah thanks very much
well meanwhile back in the uk a similar
message from the chair of the
environment agency today she said that
england needs to adapt or die as climate
change brings more extreme weather
there's a warning that the deadly flood
scene in germany and belgium this summer
could be mirrored here as could rising
sea levels and droughts unless england
becomes more resilient to violent
weather well the report also highlighted
the increase in water demands that
population growth and climate change
will bring the ea warns that if no
further action is taken between 2025 and
2050 we'll need 3.4 billion extra liters
of water per day on top of the 14
billion liters of water currently being
used daily
with 2 degrees celsius of global warming
that's below the level the world is
currently on track for england's winter
rainfall will increase by around 6
percent
increasing flooding
but summer rainfall will decrease by 15
percent by the 2050s putting crops at
risk and increasing the incidence of
droughts
and the report also warns that
increasing sea levels around london will
rise by at least 23 centimeters by the
2050s
mitigation might save the planet
it is adaptation and resilience that
will save millions of lives and
livelihoods choosing one over the other
is like telling a bird it only needs one
wing to fly
the shadow business and energy secretary
ed miliband has also been looking ahead
to cop 26 pointing out that in order to
limit global warming to one and a half
degrees the world needs to reduce annual
greenhouse gas emissions from 53
gigatonnes to 25 over the next nine
years that's a decrease of 28 gigatons
but so far reductions of less than four
have been pledged mr billaband also had
a message for boris johnson
the prime minister must treat this
summit with the seriousness it deserves
we cannot let cop 26 be the greenwash
summit
it's time for the prime minister
to get off the sun lounger
put away the easel
be a statesman and make glasgow the
success we need it to be this summit
must succeed and it still can but we
need a step change in action from our
government and governments across the
world
well there was some progress today in
the battle for carbon neutrality
courtesy of president putin he didn't
quite commit to a date but he did say
that russia would strive to be carbon
neutral by 2060. now that's a full
decade later than the uk's commitment
and it puts russia on a par with china
russia has taken practical steps to make
its economy not zero and we have been
setting concrete targets here we'd
achieve
it no later than in 2016.
well our moscow correspondent diana
magnay looks now at how significant
today's announcement might be
there you have it president putin
promising to be carbon neutral by 2060.
that's the same
commitment as china has made and it's
quite a long way off germany for example
which wants to be carbon neutral by 2045
or the eu
by 2050 but germany already has a much
heavier mix of renewables in its energy
mix and president putin pointed to the
fact that there is already uh quite a
clean energy source in russia's energy
mix 26 hydro electricity 20 to 21
nuclear power also but of course uh the
bulk of it is still fossil fuels the
economy heavily dependent on fossil fuel
extraction most of it natural gas which
is cleaner but a lot of oil and coal too
a lot of which is now going east to
china to make up for shortfalls there
this was the second major energy
conference in as many weeks this time in
moscow with uh the ceos of the big oil
majors total bp and exxon mobil sitting
up there at the plenary session
alongside president putin and they were
fairly tight-lipped about the eu's new
arctic policy unveiled today which
includes
a commitment to stop extracting oil gas
and coal from the arctic much of
russia's investment in new
fields is within the arctic circle um
and all of them really pointed to the
fact that natural gas at least had to
continue to be a bridging technology
abridging fuel
as europe and the rest of the world
pushes through its energy its green
energy transition
well the williams formula one team is
looking to beat russia comprehensively
after pledging to be climate positive by
2030 it means the racing team will go
beyond achieving net zero carbon
emissions by actually removing
additional carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere
the green party has called on the uk to
announce a carbon tax at the un climate
change conference the party is proposing
that businesses should initially have to
pay a hundred pounds per tonne of co2
released rising to 500 pounds per tonne
by 2030. the party estimates the uk will
be responsible for around 800 million
tons of co2 in 2021 and that tax would
generate up to 80 billion pounds
a wildfire has closed down a highway on
california's central coast after high
winds and dry conditions worsened by
climate change caused the fire to spread
across all four lanes around 600
firefighters are working to contain the
alisal fire which spans more than
thirteen thousand four hundred acres and
is only five percent contained according
to fire officials
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'll be joined by mikhail nakhmani
founder of climate policy radar and
michael mann distinguished professor of
atmospheric science at penn state
university and we're going to be
discussing how much power smaller
countries might have at cop26 and also
how best to talk about the impacts of
climate change
[Music]
i think sadly um along with you know
other black music artists um i've
actually received a bit of a pre-warning
of the damage that
racism in the music industry can do to
your mental health so a lot of my black
female music artistic friends have
shared with me their stories of being
told that they can't do certain genres
that they have to change their hair they
have to change the way that they talk um
in order to kind of get ahead in this
industry um so i've kind of positioned
myself knowing of the damage it can do
to mental health i position myself a
little bit on the outskirts of the music
industry and even still i've had
experiences where companies and labels
have made it clear that there's only
room for one black artist on their
roster or one artist that does black
music the industry needs to work
together uh we need to collaborate all
of us that's what real diversity means
we need
to look at
transparency in terms of earnings we've
already seen that
in the industry that
black music creators and industry
professionals earn less black women
specifically earn considerably less
we need to have that transparency and
understand what's going on we need to
give support at grassroots level and we
also need to give support in terms of
well-being people like leanne pinnock
obviously from little mix have spoken
out and keisha from
the sugar babes and also alexandra burke
so i do think there's an attention on
this issue right now which is great i
just do think um as roger said that
there needs to be more collaboration
more transparency i think our culture of
not really talking about music kind of
does us a disservice
i i love to talk about uh you know talk
about money and the what people are
being paid in the music industry uh
because i think that helps to um avoid
uh pay disparity as well and hopefully
having a body in any other industry
you'd have kind of a hr body that you
could go to
and i think black lives and music is
perfectly set up for this role to be
able to hold leaders to account and to
get everyone together to collaborate to
make the music industry more fair
we're seeing um artists who
start at the top and work their way very
quickly down to the bottom with without
the support
of the industry so we must work together
we must collaborate and give support so
that there's a level playing field for
everyone regardless of their color
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
founder and chief executive of climate
policy radar dr mikhail nakhmani and
distinguished professor of atmospheric
science at penn state university dr
michael mann very good to see you both
good evening to you and so first of all
let's go to our first subject and
ireland nation leaders are calling cop
26 a make or break moment for their
survival now they want at least half of
the promise 100 billion dollars a year
in climate funding from rich countries
to go directly to adaptation measures
now only a quarter is currently
allocated to it and the most vulnerable
countries in the world say that will be
too little and it's rapidly becoming too
late so mikhail i don't know if you know
but we've lost a michael mann he dropped
out behind me there while i was
introducing you but hopefully we'll get
him back in a moment but first of all so
this call from these uh climate
vulnerable nations these island states
saying that cop 26 is make or break for
them
what do you think it's going to be is it
going to be make or break will the rich
nation step up and give them the help
they need
when we look in the eyes of small island
states leaders we are looking at the eye
of climate change and first of all
there's a moral imperative to make that
happen and i think cop 26 is an
excellent opportunity for world leaders
to do that and to uh understand that
this is it
now this is it because climate change is
not something that's happening in 2030
or in 2013 or in 2050 climate change is
already here and has already been here
for small island states as we've seen
in your excellent piece about granada
the climate finance that has been
promised as
as we know is completely insufficient to
meet the adaptation needs of those
small island states
and in a way it is almost like choosing
between a vaccine and a treatment if we
start weighing off adaptation versus
mitigation
climate change uh is already impacting
those countries in a way that is
irreversible for some of them
but i think that we have an interesting
opportunity here because small island
states have proved in the past
especially around the paris agreement
that they have significant power to
impact those debates well yes okay they
were the one they were the ones who
spearheaded for example the crucial
language on well below two degrees that
um managed to get into the paris
agreement uh and spearheaded excellent
ambition and advanced the debate on loss
and damage i'm just going to cut in
because we've got michael backs we want
to celebrate that by by bringing him in
um sorry we lost you just for a moment
there michael but let's pick up on that
point that mikhail was making there that
nations like the marshall islands made a
real difference didn't they around the
paris agreement by by stepping up
putting pressure on at just the right
time could that happen again this time
round and how much power do those
smaller nations have in negotiations
like this
well they've got the power of their
voice um and and they have to tell the
stories um people have to understand
that you know when we talk about
dangerous climate change being at a
degree and a half celsius or two degrees
celsius dangerous climate change has
arrived for these people um if you're
one of the caribbean islands if you're
puerto rico it was devastated by uh this
monster storm hurricane maria
just a few years ago they are feeling
the dangerous impacts of climate change
now and they can't wait any longer and
unfortunately they have the least
resources um
and they've had the least role in
creating this problem in the first place
and so there's really an ethical
obligation on the part of the industrial
countries of the world that really
fundamentally created this problem in
the first place to provide all the
assistance that they can to them and and
these countries they need to use their
voice the moral authority of the stories
that they can tell about the
you know the truly devastating impacts
that they are now seeing
to wake us all up and to put pressure on
our policymakers to act now michael very
briefly how much of the changes are
already locked in for these islands
well you know i i like to i'll often
take sort of uh doomists to task for
overstating you know the the the the
challenge that we face for you know um
for presenting climate change as an
unsolvable problem um
something that will lead to our
extinction but you know it's hard to be
too optimistic with some of these
low-lying island nations they really are
facing an existential crisis they will
lose their homes they will lose
everything they have and so some of that
is locked in it's baked in there's a
certain amount of additional sea level
rise that's baked in if we can hold
warming to one and a half degrees
celsius which is we already saw earlier
we heard we need to bring carbon
emissions down by 50 within this decade
but if we can do that we can probably
hold warming below one and a half
degrees celsius probably limit sea level
rise to under a meter where there's
still the potential to adapt to those
impacts okay we're going to move on to
our second subject now because here the
environment agency's chief has given us
a stark warning saying we must adapt or
die when it comes to dealing with
extreme weather brought about by climate
change and similar language has been
used by world leaders and environmental
groups to shock people into action but
does it always work mikhail to you first
of all i'm just going to put a statistic
to you apparently 56 of young people
think that humanity is doomed so
should we talk in these kind of terms
does it frighten people and put people
off the climate change cause or does it
prompt people to take action
we need to do both
we need to make sure that everyone is
aware that we are in a place and in a
time that we need to act right now
and unfortunately being in the comfort
zone and telling us no you know what
everything is fine and you just have to
use some plastic straws and everything
will be fine that's not going to cut it
and we know that so we need to describe
reality as it is in reality as it is is
pretty scary but if we stop there
that's not going to take us anywhere so
the next thing that we have to do is be
angry about it a little bit and it's um
and we need to be angry because we did
this and we made decisions along the way
the collectively that led to this
but if we stop there that's not good
enough either because right the next
step that we need to take is agency
and everything in all the science and
all the ipcc reports and everything that
we know teaches us and tells us that we
still can make a difference
so we take this um sadness and we take
this anger and we channel it into agency
that's where we need to go so adapt or
die is exactly a call for action it is
um if we don't
then we will uh suffer great
circumstances but we can okay michael
what do you think a message of fear or
message of hope what works best
i think mccall you know uh spelled it
out right here um it's urgency and
agency yes we're already facing
devastating consequences of human-caused
climate change and it will get much
worse if we fail to take action that's
the urgency we can see the urgency we're
literally seeing the the you know the
the dangerous and damaging impacts of
climate change play out in real time now
that's the urgency the agency as mccall
says we have time to prevent the worst
it's going to be a monumental challenge
and cop26 is where we have to make it
happen this is our moment if we are
going to keep warming uh to a level that
we can still adapt to that will remain
within our adaptive capacity we need to
see substantial action now and that's
what cop 26 has to be about okay we will
leave it on that note with mikhail
nodding mikhail michael good to see you
thanks very much indeed